[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 60 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandela hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks Francesca how
are you doing I'm pretty tired it's been
a long day it is a saturday and i've
been working at I think I mean working
I've been having fun at foss them all
day long but also very happy to be here
for a very awesome interview actually
how are you how are you lemon let's not
be doing I how are you doing I'm good
it's a Saturday but you know what with
travel schedules and work thing how it
is this is when we found time to record
yeah I'm also excited about today's
episode we're talking about fezzes
functions as a service I've never
actually said the word fast before I
think that's how you pronounce it how
else could you pronounce it I don't know
fast like it was fun like like the ice
cream haagen-dazs it's fast you know
what I could give I could get behind
fast I could do far as that would I
actually I like that a lot well yeah
we're talking with so um vasani about
fishing the functions as a service thing
that works on top of Coober Nettie's so
that's pretty cool it is pretty awesome
because basically the way it happened is
that we gave them a shout out during our
last episode it was one of the cool
things of the week and we said hey it'd
be awesome if you're listening to this
let us know and we like to interview you
well that happened basically much we're
like hey what are you doing on Saturday
so yeah pretty awesome and after that
interview with some we're gonna have our
question of the week which is about all
the things that I love networking so
HTTPS and web sockets and load balancing
or how do you make all of those things
work together nicely on Google cloud
platform before we do that though why
don't we get stuck into our cool things
of the week let's say that oh we have so
many where do we want to start i said i
will start with one of my favorite
things obviously kuba native
avacs one of my favorite topics so
there's an article that came out on the
curb minetti's blog about running highly
available crouppen eighties clusters so
basically the standard community system
right now runs on a single master that
works reasonably well in that if the
master falls over and it's fine doesn't
actually destroy anything but if people
have been looking for multi master
setups especially high availability
setups across multiple regions there's a
great article showing how that's
currently been supported on Google
compute engine in the Ku benetti's 1.5
release and shows you all the commands
you need to use to set that up which is
nice so what what happens now if you're
saying that if you now we have two
masters for higher availability what
happens if you have a master and it goes
down that's that means that the whole
cluster goes out no it doesn't which is
pretty good so you should monitor your
masters that's important but if your
master does go down all your pods
continue to keep running like they would
do normally so this is how you can do
upgrades and you know if if something
horrible happens and that's great then
that's not right that's not something
horrible happens then you're covered
right your service is not gonna go down
and your systems I'm gonna go down but
if your muscly goes down keep an eye on
it and then bring it back up quickly but
it's not gonna mean your services are
going to die which is pretty cool nice
uh following on the topic of Cobra
Nettie's there is another blog post to
medium posts from jacopo daily I'm gonna
assume he's Italian and it's about
Cooper Nettie's and how to do continuous
deployment to Google container engine we
strive sei yeah it's pretty cool he
steps you through all the things I
learned something new in this I was
looking through it there's a cube CTL
set image command that lets you change
images on deployments and damen sets and
stuff I've done that by editing yellow
files and then applying but it's kind of
cool you can do it just in a single
command yeah that that is cool i didn't
know either that you could do that
actually it's pretty fun why don't we go
to the third and last question the
question now cool thing of the week
which is about sickle server enterprise
I think that now we have pre-configured
images for them right yeah it looks like
we have pre-configured images
for Microsoft sequel server enterprise
and windows server core on compute
engine cool and I think that one of the
coolest parts of this is that there are
there's also some instructions to set
them up with high availability and
disaster recovery which means that
basically you're going to be running
every single instance in a different
zone so even if one whole zone goes down
you still have your database running all
the time which is very important and
this has to recover which means that you
will not lose a single piece of data
which is something that we all want to
have I think this is also kind of cool
it's mentioned here as well that finally
all of the windows server images are now
enabled with windows remote management
support which is pretty nice if you need
to manage fleets of Windows machines
nice cool I think it's time to go talk
to some old fishing what do you think
sounds good to me let's go do that so
today's episode is brought to you by
what happens when you reach out via
podcast and say hey it would be really
great if we interviewed that person on
the podcast and they listened to the
podcast and then they come and they are
on the podcast which is really cool so I
would like to introduce so on bassani so
um thank you so much for joining us
today how are you doing great how are
you thanks for having me yeah really
really good um before we get stuck into
talking about fishing I oh why don't you
tell us a little bit about who you are
what you do the company work for all
that sort of good stuff yeah so I joined
platform 9 about a year ago it's a
company that does SAS managed it started
out as a SAS managed system for on-prem
infrastructure so people who had their
hosts and you'd get an online control
plane for them and we started doing open
stack and then about a year ago started
working with co benetti's as well and i
worked for a while at vmware that's
that's how I know some of the people who
started the company and I had worked at
on various things at VMware
infrastructure management stuff some
storage systems and some other random
projects in between and so I so I joined
here and was working on this kubin IDs
management plane and then
maybe about four to six months ago
started working on fishing cool and what
what is your role on fission so I am the
software engineer on it it's it's
actually just mainly just one person
right now so I guess I'm software
engineer and doing a little bit of
marketing you can say but talking about
it due to other people as well so yeah a
little bit of everything cool so I'm
actually curious about you told you told
the story a little bit of how you got
started with coronaries but how that how
did fission io sound like when did
someone be like oh we should have like
functions on culinary's could you tell a
bit about that yeah yeah so so that the
actual thing started in a in a hackathon
we have these little internal company
hackathons every few months and I I'd
been simultaneously excited about AWS
lambda and server less around the same
time and also because we were we were
taking Cuban Eddie's to two companies
who who hadn't really worked with
containers before at all and so so both
dr. and Cuban IDs were new to them they
would they knew that they were you know
excited about communities and wanted to
use it and we take it to them and deploy
it and then they would there the next
question would be you know how do i do
something useful with this and we didn't
have any helpful answer other than you
know go read the manual try out some
examples and so on so we really wanted
something where we can give users
something where a simple really simple
app can be brought up in you know the
first day that you have a cabana DS
cluster and and so this hackathon
provided like a really you know a short
way to make some kind of prototype
that's when we made this nodejs thing
which basically wrapped an odious
function at runtime into a into a
container and brought it up as a service
that you could start doing requests to
it so it is an early prototype about six
months ago cool so like on the fission
website it says serverless functions for
communities yeah does that mean what is
that what does that actually look
like say like as a developer experience
and also just conceptually yeah so ah so
you know even though we say functions is
actually more deals more properly so
yeah see you right there so the
programmer writes a node.js or Python
module with with one function as the
entry point as the sole export of that
module and then fission takes that and
turns it into an HTTP service that runs
on Cuban eddies and it also manages the
lifecycle of that service creating it
instantiating it when there's a request
killing it when it's idle scaling it
potentially things like that so so the
programmer has a simple interface they
write a module and a function which
takes in context the context contains
the request and so on and they just
implement the service there and then
fission is responsible for taking it
from a source code file to a running
service on communities cool so you
mentioned one thing which I guess it's
because of the way you build your
containers which is you said that you
were able to do python and no Jas I'm I
myself a little bit of a gopher yeah is
it go coming at some point is there is
there any reasons why go is not
supporting inside you're supporting
these languages that are interpreted
which I assume there's theories yeah
yeah so this this is an exciting topic
this is what we're working on right now
yay so today today your function it goes
from a source code file directly into
the execution environment and fission
framework hits the dynamic loader that's
inside that container and loads that
function and routes request to it so now
we want to enhance this pipeline a bit
to add support for compiled languages to
add support for a dependency resolution
step so you know installing dependencies
linking them in whatever way as defined
in the language so so what we're doing
is take a step back looking at how we
define these language environment and
saying okay today we just have an
execution environment now you also need
a build environment and the build
environment is
vision will just say okay your source
code goes as some sort of artifact into
the build environment and in the
language specific way the build
environment turns that source artifact
into a dynamically loadable runnable
artifact so so you basically get so for
in the case of go you would upload a a
set of source files and maybe some spec
of dependencies and then and then the
Builder would output either a binary or
maybe plugins using goes newish plugin
support and then the execution
environment would would load that plugin
and fission would be responsible for
orchestrating this running the build
when the when the user uploads a
function you know managing compile
errors and that iteration cycle and then
transporting the binary storing it
cashing it and so on so go support is
the infrastructure for go support is
being built right now and then and then
on top of that will build the goal and
support do you have other languages in
the pipeline as well yeah so we already
have node.js Python somebody contributed
PHP and c-sharp dotnet the c-sharp
dotnet support is interesting because
it's a compiled language but what it
does is it compiles it at runtime so you
know that's that's an interesting way to
do it it's it's not it's not ideal we
want to change that but but it is
supported for now so so yeah those are
the languages there's a contributor
who's working on Ruby right now and and
yeah like I said we're working on the
support for compiled languages cool um
so you touched on a little bit before
but I'd like to sort of talk about it
specifically like why serverless like
why why is that a thing like what does
that mean to you and like why was this
so important to you when you know you
came up with this project yes I think so
the stump serverless itself is a bit
vague right we so I think the general
idea is that is to sort of ask what
what's the simplest interface
you can have to write applications that
still can be used in production that's
still useful usable to create services
in production and I think this functions
as a service is one approach to that I'd
say sir 100 wasn't proven yet but you
know we're we're we think it'll get
their service so I think functions as a
service is sort of a maybe a more a more
precise or a more specific form of
serverless but don't see a question why
serverless I think it's there's there's
a pattern there of saying how simple can
we make this and still it still be
useful right and yeah I think that's
different approaches to that and
functions as services is one approach
that dynamic side robot so the question
that I have now it's the question like
pretty much started this episode which
was you know like not that long ago we
had the monolith right and we had one
binary and for that binary we had a
bunch of code that's it now next we move
to micro services and also and we have a
bunch of different wineries or processes
and at the same time we might have a
bunch of different repos and then now
we're moving to functions and and
curious about how do you manage the
complexity of having so many different
and different pieces of source code that
are somehow related but possibly a store
in different places how do you manage
them says few questions that I think
when you have a large set of functions
kind of how do you put them together
like we decomposed our application to
into a bunch of little pieces now how do
we put the pieces back together right
and and compatibility is one of the
issues there so so I think this is a bit
of an open area for functions of the
service I think it's it's a it's a bit
of a language and framework design
problem so we're going to try a few
things so I think one thing that we need
is support for some sort of
composability so
you need using code to be able to
compose other functions together today
to din the most of the faz
implementations don't don't do that very
well you just you create an event or
HTTP request and you can you can call
other functions but there isn't a formal
way to call other functions through
through the framework itself and so so
we need that so you need some sort of
composability and I think we need some
sort of grouping either modules
namespaces packages something like that
that can let you assemble your functions
together so you still have some notion
of separation between functions but a
program after all like you said is a is
many functions and modules so so you
need some construction to to group them
and then that will also help with the
compatibility question because then you
can version the repository as a whole so
we don't have any of this today but it's
you know some some ideas on what to do
for example you might have a git repo
with with a manifest at the top level
something it looks kind of like a cumin
idml file and so it would say okay this
function is this sub directory or this
set of files over here is forms a
function here it imports that module
over there and this other set of files
is is this other function and and the
whole thing is versioned as a whole and
so you could you could imagine deploying
you could imagine pointing the efficient
tools at at that manifest and and the
thing wraps it up as some sort of
package and envision figures out how to
run that so that's very hand wavy and a
little vague but that we want to
experiment with something like that it's
like I said it's not a solved problem
and and where we're going to try things
out and see see how that goes today
today the main utility tends to be pick
up maybe because of this problem in
smaller use cases
especially like event handling and web
hooks a small slack bar that sort of
thing okay that's that's actually what I
was going to actually segue into which
is great I was going to ask you then
given given what you said like what what
do you think the major use cases for
this I know personally like when I
looked at this the fact that fishing can
handle not only HTTP events but also
kerber Nettie's events yeah to do like
the glue stuff within communities was
that kind of what you think it would be
used for what what are the what are the
use cases you think you're going to be
particularly useful here so I think
initially it's very useful for small
rest api's and you know maybe a web hook
is basically one endpoint REST API you
could you could say and you no slack
bots and little automation like okay
let's pipe events from google ad czar or
other sources into the system and use
that to glue it into into other
infrastructure i expect that to be like
the main use case and and I see like the
actual usage also tends to be like that
so we have international usage where you
know some CI systems or automated builds
trigger some functions and we track you
know test failures and so on using these
things the the idea of having a bigger
app implemented this way it's definitely
something we'd like to reach but that's
a definitely a more speculative use case
like we'll have to see how that goes i
am excited about that use case i think
it's it's real it would be really nice
to be able to specify mostly in the
language neutral way how how you know a
REST API should be deployed and run on
fission and and have vision like take
care of that of the deployment and
scaling and things like that but we're
not we're not quite there yet for bigger
programs so how much liquor is you
mentioned a couple of use cases like
managing some events and stuff could you
tell us a little bit about what are the
use cases for which you think that
functions as a service is on
better metaphor then let's say
infrastructure of the service or
platform as a service so uh this again
like today the event handling stuff is
is the best use case for for that if you
if you just want to write say some
trigger for for example we have we are
just discussing this within the company
a few days ago we have this source code
cross-referencing tool that today poll
target repositories and so we figured we
could just we could change it to have a
small web hook that's triggered from
trigger every time you do a commit to a
repo and that and that web hook would go
and book this source code indexing thing
that would reindex whatever changed or
at least the repo that changed and then
you wouldn't have to pull the git repo
so so now if you imagine implementing
this as either infrastructure as a
service or microservices you have to
it's a little bit more involved you have
to create the service around it if
you're if you're running it on the vm
you have to worry about the whole
operating system if you're on Cooper
Nettie's you're definitely a bit better
off but but I think where this function
service helps is that you don't have to
worry about you don't quite have to
worry as much about about the capacity
of the cluster in terms of the number of
services you deploy so in some sense
creating a service becomes cheaper both
in terms of development costs and
runtime infrastructure costs so so
basically our cluster capacity becomes
more a function of usage then of the
size and number of services that you've
deployed cool so I'm curious person else
as well vision is built on top of
communities why'd you choose communities
is the platform what was the reasoning
behind that yeah yeah so ah so few
different things one is that coo
bilities provides so much of the stuff
that we'd have to build if we didn't use
communities or something like
that from a purely implementation point
of view it just makes a lot of sense we
we don't we don't even know about nodes
cover IDs completely takes care of the
cluster management itself we don't have
any real scheduler we might have some
scheduling decisions to make but coburn
Eddie's takes care of the bulk of
scheduling decisions we don't have to do
any complex storage integration we would
just be able to use coburn IDs volumes
you know there's networking secret
management so so in terms of
implementations like Cobra dis takes us
way ahead then where we would if we if
we started without it so that's that's
one story from an implementation point
of view from a from a user's point of
view we think so I I don't think
functions as a service will replace the
idea of micro services or you know just
putting services in containers and
running long-lived services because
there's plenty of use cases where where
you want to do that for a you know like
let's say you're running red is it
doesn't make any sense to do kill red is
when it isn't doing request because it
would lose all its memory so obviously
that has to be a long-lived process so
if you if you're using that then the
question is as part of your bigger as
part of your overall solution how do you
how do you mix together functions as a
service and regular services and I think
cubana DS is a good place to bring those
all together because you can get service
discovery maybe between these things and
and yeah you can just easily have them
on the same cluster you could in the
future maybe do some smart things with
scheduling and what else yeah basically
interrupt with with services the
implementation advantages the reuse of
Cuban Ares concepts like secrets volumes
and so on and I think is also an
operational benefit like you don't want
to run two clusters for one
services and 14 functions it's better to
have fewer systems that you manage right
so if you're already managing a
company's cluster managing its nodes
managing at CD and its stay then you
might as well spend that you might have
a reuse that effort to run functions on
and so if you have you know something
like a log monitoring framework and
monitoring stuff like Prometheus you
could you could just reuse that with
vision cool so I'm curious about you
were talking about all the cool things
about building on coburn at ease so I'm
gonna go the other way and ask you what
was the biggest challenge of about
building something like fusion on top of
luminaries you know for the most part
like once week once I got past the
learning curve figured out how to use
the client a lot of things was super
doable the API is very complete it's
very comprehensive I can talk about a
few challenges that we just haven't
solved yet so so one thing is volumes
right I spoke about how it's awesome
that we can reuse good melodies storage
management but the way volumes work
conflicts with the way we dynamically
load functions so okay so let me roll
back a bit when we started this we we
tried to just take a function wrap it in
a in an image and just do just create a
community's deployment and a service
using that image on demand but that
takes a few seconds at best even if you
you know pre pull the image and cash it
everywhere that still takes a few
seconds so and and when people do
function service the expect a faster
cold start off on the order of 100
milliseconds even less sometimes but but
that's the goal we've aim for so far so
to do that we needed to have already
running parts and and so when you create
a when you add support for node.js to
python or sorry notice up
then to fishin then fission creates a
pool of these parts that are already
running before you even have any
requests for a function and then when
the request comes in the functions
loaded in there and run and that and
that has a smaller overhead because the
overhead of starting a pod was already
taken before the request came in okay so
now what to do with things like volumes
because it's it's not possible today
neither in darker narco binaries to
mount a volume on an existing running
part as far as i know i have i've tried
to figure this out but it looks like
that is not possible today so if your
function wants to use a volume then then
you have to lose the cold start
optimization which means you have to
start the part when the function request
comes in or we have to figure out
something separate from from the way
volumes work today like maybe have a
separate part that then that then the
function can connect to to get at its
storage something like that but but yeah
basically mounting storage is is a
challenge we we haven't figured out yet
maybe one of our listeners might be able
to help with that yeah I hope so yeah
but yeah today today the answer is that
we would have maybe some sort of
separate mode where you just where you
lose the cold shot optimization if you
really want volume ok cool so I have one
more very short question what language
that you used to implement oh it's all
him go nice yeah it's actually my first
non-trivial go project so very much
learning as I go I'm I had a few sort of
initial puzzling moments with go but but
now I like it a lot and I'm very excited
to be using it I sort of started with it
because gubin editor is written in it
and and also it seemed to be getting
popular I didn't have a strong like
reason to adopt one over the you know go
over something like nor jets which is
what I was familiar with before but yeah
I've I've really enjoyed making this
single cool all right we're also
definitely running out of time so very
quickly what is the plans for the future
what's in the roadmap for fishin yeah so
I think we addressed a few major pieces
of effort that the current the current
major effort is improving that function
pipelines reporting compiled languages
after that we want to get at improving
the developer workflow a bit you know
dealing with having better support for
versioning we have very very basic
versioning support today there is
support but it it's it's a bit manual ah
you know doesn't interrupt with get as
nicely as we like and then there's more
language support better integration with
Cuban Eddie's volume secrets config maps
oh yeah and of course integrations with
more event sources integrations with
some sort of message queue there's
there's not maybe Kafka or something
like that and and finally we have a lot
of performance tuning to do we don't do
auto scaling today but we need to do
that both up and down things like that
and and also latency improvements both
in cold you are done in the fast path
cool all right uh so um thank you so
much for joining today I think we're
gonna have to cut it there just because
I running out of time but really I
appreciate you yet definitely for coming
down and and talking to us especially on
a Saturday we really love that it was
really interesting to talk about fishing
with you this is awesome thank you so
much for having me thank you great that
was a great interview with some thank
you so much for taking the times as you
said especially on a Saturday to talk to
us and tell us a little bit about why
and how you implemented a fuss out of of
coronaries yeah no super super cool I'm
yeah as I said before I'm quite
interested in how you can use this to
basically build like quick little bits
of glue inside communities and
connecting that
the things yeah I'm very excited
specially about the about the go support
coming soon maybe using go plugins which
is something that's coming with go on
the date that we release actually
probably right now as we're talking the
go under day will be released on
Wednesday so that that should be cool
cool all right well why don't we move
into our questions the lake I know you
had a particularly interesting one about
web sockets yeah so as I was saying at
the beginning of the episode is about
you know it's like something that I
really don't know that much but it is
important many people know that you know
if you have a global service you need to
do load balancing and many people know
that if you want to have a very
responsive web page web sockets can help
you and we all know that it is important
to secure all of the things with HTTPS
but when you try to use web sockets over
HTTPS load balancer if you read the
documentation it says no you cannot do
that well what's what's the deal with
this okay what what is going on here
what is going on what is going on so you
know it's a good question and when I've
definitely run into before so yes if
you're doing HTTP or HTTPS load
balancing we have a global layer 7 load
balancer that help support that that
load balancer doesn't support web
sockets so it's like what do I do so
WebSockets themselves on HTTP web site
gets run over TCP protocol they're like
negotiated and kind of managed by like
HTTP by the browser and the servers to
like how where do i connect to and where
but they are TCP connection so we need a
TCP load balancer is essentially what we
need and goo Club platform has a TCP
load balancer which is great but what we
also want is we want as a cell support
because much like HTTP and HTTPS right
security good yeah yeah so what we can
do then is we set up a TCP load balancer
a network load balancer but we set it up
with what's called an ssl proxy and one
once we do that seems pretty much work
as you would expect so when you go to
setup your network load balancer and
actually the the the console to the
console cloud google com has a really
nice interface for this now where if you
go in there and you're like hey i need
load balancing for my network
Eric it'll give you the options you can
then select TCP load balancing and then
when you go in to configure it'll
actually ask you connection termination
do you want an ssl proxy or do you just
want straight tcp so you're then able to
select proxy and then go configure from
there my cell you're totally able to do
web sockets you just need a slightly
different type of load balancer to run
them over a little sigh question about
it you mentioned that you know that when
it's a ssl load balancer you can choose
tcp is there anything else I can choose
can you choose UDP yeah you can totally
do that as well it actually has that as
three options when you go in like HTTP
or HTS load balancing TTYL balancing as
well as UDP load balancing as well
awesome cool alright well I think that's
kind of bring things to a close
Francesca you up to anything
particularly interesting is there a just
for funk I hear there might be just for
funk yes I did release a new just for
fun episode finally and and it was very
successful it is a implementing flappy
bird I call it flappy gopher because
it's really lingo and any two days he
got almost 3,000 views so I got people
like it yeah lots of fun and also I I've
been working with these with the go
plugins actually that come we'd go on
the right and i wrote a demo about it
and we'll have a link to that so if you
want to do like hot code swapping in go
which is something he was not doable
until like this version i check out the
repo it's everything on github already
so it's easy and what about you what
about me when this comes out there will
be April post live on my website I
literally just write one for if you're a
game developer and you want to come to
cloud next which is literally like the
week after at GDC and you want to come
there and you're like hey maybe there's
some game development sessions that are
relevant for me there are actually quite
a few so if you do anything with
back-end or multiplayer games or
anything like that we even have stuff
around location but based games and also
the interesting stuff may be well worth
a read but otherwise yeah just getting
ready for GDC and Max that's my those
are my big things are you seeking a huge
next is gonna be huge yeah I'm yeah for
me it is going
be you know coming back to San Francisco
soon and then go for Connie India and
then cloud banks which is going to be
pretty intense as you're saying but you
know ready for that are very excited a
lot of pop cast things going on for that
so very excited about all the planning
and hopefully seeing many of our
listeners out there yeah absolutely i'm
you know we will be set up at cloud
necks or please come up say hello we may
have some swag we may yes we i'm sure
we'll have some t-shirts t-shirts
stickers will find some stuff will
definitely find some stuff cool so i
think that today it's a very good day to
remember to remind our listeners how
they can get in touch with us if they
want to ask questions or propose some
topics or to say that you know they love
us whatever they feel like they say so
why don't we do that let's do it the
other way around today so i'm gonna say
the medium and you say the the handle
okay okay so let's start with the easy
ones we have a web page gcp podcast calm
or cloud or google com / podcast great
we do have an email to hello at GSP
podcast and we invite the ephemeral
correctly we have twitter at gcp podcast
we have google plus plus gcp podcast we
are on reddit at / r / gcp podcast on
myspace now another myspace which one
arrow i'm forgetting slack we're also
that i have a channel yeah hash podcast
on the slack google cloud community and
i think that's it that is it ya know i
just wanna make a quick shout out like
if you do something that's cool like if
you're like hey this i wrote a blog post
or i have an open source project or
anything like that and you think it'd be
interesting for the podcast please send
it through we're always looking for more
cool things to the week done by the
community and also something that we
proposed last year if you have questions
and you'd like to send it and send them
to us as a as an audio file that'd be
awesome so we could use your own voice
on our podcast that we awesome you
become basically famous instantly
Nestle so you know this is an
opportunity to take absolutely alright
great well Francis thank you for joining
me yet again for another week thank you
for waking up early on a Saturday no
problem and talk to you all next week
yeah talk to y'all next week
you
[Music]